YOU NEXT SATURDAY NIGHT.
>> LOOKS LIKE A TIRED CRAZY
RIGHT NOW AND JOE BIDEN, HE
LOOKS LIKE HE'S JUST EXHAUSTED.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM BUT HE LOOKS EXHAUSTED.
HE DOESN'T DO ANY WORK.
>> QUINNIPIAC SAYS SANDERS,
BIDEN, WARREN, PETE BUTTIGIEG
WILL BEAT YOU?
>> THEY HAD ME LOSING TEXAS TO
POCAHONTAS, I'M NOT LOSING TEXAS
TO ANYBODY?
>> SO MUCH FUN TO READ IT IN
SPANISH.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> HIS NAME IS GEORGE
WASHINGTON.
>> GEORGE IS AT 100% IS NO WAY
I'M GOING TO GET THERE NO MATTER
WHAT I TELL YOU.
>> OH, MAN, WHAT ABOUT THE WALL?
IS IT MOVING ALONG?
>> THE WALL IS MOVING ALONG,
IT'S MOVING ALONG RAPIDLY.  IT'S
BEAUTIFUL, STRONGER, BIGGER,
BETTER AND CHEAPER, SOMETIMES
WHEN THEY DON'T GIVE YOU THE
MONEY, YOU TO MAKE IT CHEAPER.
>> IT'S TRUE, DO WE HAVE TO PAY?
>> YOU PAY FOR THE VERY DISTINCT
PRIVILEGE OF NOT HAVING TO PAY,
BUT YOU HAD TO PAY A LOT.
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY
ANYMORE.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT
MEANT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> BUT I ASK, DO YOU NEED A
MAGIC WAND?
>> YOU NEED A MAGIC WAND TO
BRING BACK MANUFACTURING, WELL,
WE WILL TELL SLEEPY JOE THAT WE
FOUND THE MAGIC WAND.
>> AT LEAST HE HAS BRILLIANT
TALENTED CAMPAIGN PEOPLE.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF BRILLIANT
BRILLIANT-TALENT CAMPAIGN
PEOPLE, THEY COST A FORTUNE AND
THEY NEVER GIVE ME ANY IDEAS,
I'M ONLY KIDDING.
>> YOU KNOW HE'S NOT KIDDING, IT
MAKES YOU WONDER WHAT COUNTRY
YOU'RE IN.
>> MAGA, MAGA, WE ARE IN MAGA
COUNTRY I CAN TELL YOU.
>> I CAN TELL YOU MAGA IS NO
LONGER THE MOTTO, IT'S KEEP
AMERICA GREAT.
SEE THE FIRST MOTTO MAGA SAID
IT'S TIME FOR A CHANGE, THE NEW
ONE SAYS LET'S PRESERVE WHAT
WE'VE CHANGED.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THE SLOGAN
FOR HIS THIRD TERM.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> ANYWAY, THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE,
PEOPLE, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT AS HE THROWS HIS FIRST
POLITICAL TAILGATE THE ORLANDO
PAPER PULLED FIRST TWO AND
ANTIENDORSEMENT OF TRUMP EVEN
BEFORE THE DEMS HAVE A NOMINEE,
MEANING THEY HATE TRUMP SO MUCH
THE DEMS COULD NOT NOMINATE A
ZOMBIE RACCOON AND GO WITH
ZOMBIE RACCOON, BUT ENOUGH OF
BERNIE SANDERS, I STILL THINK
IT'S INFANTILE MUCH LIKE CNN
AFTER BEING INSULTED AT THE
RALLY ACTUALLY SHUT THEIR
COVERAGE DOWN, PROVING HOW
EMOTIONAL THEY REALLY ARE, I'M
SURPRISE THEY DIDN'T SAY SAY I
HATE ALL OF YOU AND RAN UPSTAIRS
AND CLOSED THE DOOR SOBBING INTO
A PILLOW, AT LEAST THEY PROVIDED
COVERAGE FOR CREEPY STUFF.
>> THE ACADEMIC DEFINITION OF
CONCENTRATION CAMPS ARE
TARGETING A COMMUNITY AND
PUTTING THEM IN DETENTION CAMPS
WITHOUT A TRIAL.
THAT'S WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
>> AND THE GENOCIDE OF THE JEWS,
YES.
>> SO AS ONE SIDE CELEBRATES A
COUNTRY, THE OTHER FLOATS IN AN
IMPERVIOUS IDIOTIC BUBBLE
INSULTING HOLOCAUST VICTIMS AND
JUSTIFYING WITH LAME SEMANTICS,
AGAIN, THE CONTRAST, THIS IS
TRUMP.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CRAZY GROUP AND THIS IS THE
CRITICS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU CAN DO IT.
NOW, I'M BAD AT PREDICTING
THINGS BUT THE SIDE HAVING MOST
FUN USUALLY WIN, ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE IT'S FUN AND ON
THE DEMOCRATS IT'S A FUNK, DEEP
SMALL SMELLY BOTTOM OF THE
HAMPER FUNK, YOU KNOW WHERE THE
SOCKS HAVE GONE STIFF.
EVERY CANDIDATE STAKING OUT THE
GLOOMIEST VISION OF THE COUNTRY,
THANK HEAVEN TRUMP WILL BE
LIVE-TWEETING THE DEBATE.
HOW OFTEN IS THAT?
PEOPLE WON'T BE WATCHING THE
DEBATES, THEY'LL BE WATCHING HIM
WATCHING DEBATES.
IF SOMEONE CAN MAKE AMY
KLOBUCHAR INTERESTING IT'S TRUMP
AND HIS TWEET MACHINE.
[LAUGHTER]
HARD TO SEE HOW SPECIAL IT IS
WHEN YOU'RE IN IT, ONE OF THOSE
TIMES THAT CAN BE REVEALED BACK
AT IT DECADES FROM NOW.
LUCKY FOR YOU I TOOK THE TIME
MACHINE IN THE FUTURE AND FOUND
THE PERFECT PRODUCT.
>> I OWN TOM, DO YOU FORGET IN
JUST A FEW MINUTES, WELL, I'M
THRILLED TO SHARE WITH YOU A
COLLECTION OF NO OTHER.
>> I WON'T TALK ABOUT JEB BUSH,
I WILL NOT SAY, I WILL NOT SAY
HE'S LOW ENERGY, I WILL NOT SAY
IT.
I WILL NOT SAY IT.
>> NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
UNFORGETTABLE TRUMP HITS ARE
TOGETHER IN ONE MUST-HAVE
SELECTION.
STAR UNICORN ENTERTAINMENT AND
GREG PRESENT THE BEST OF TRUMP.
>> WE WILL BUILD THE WALL.
AND WHO IS GOING TO PAY FOR THE
WALL?
>> BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY COHOST KAT
KEMF.
>> YOU MIGHT RECOGNIZE WITH
TITANIC 17, JACK'S REVENGE, BUT
TODAY I'M EXCITED TO LOOK BACK
ON THE VOICE THAT DEFINED AN
ERA.
>> DONALD SUPPORTED THE INVASION
OF IRAQ.
>> WRONG.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY PROVED OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
>> WRONG.
>> HE ACTUALLY-
>> THE BEST OF TRUMP IS GREAT SO
WHEN YOU WANT TO HAVE FRIENDS
OVER.
>> LIKE ME IF YOU DON'T HAVE
FRIENDS.
>> I'M OFFICIALLY RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND WE ARE GOING TO MAKE OUR
COUNTRY GREAT AGAIN.
>> THIS COLLECTION BRINGS BACK
SO MANY MEMORIES LIKE BEFORE MY
WIFE LEFT ME FOR GERALDO.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, TOM, WITH MORE
THAN 47,000 HOURS OF CONTENT
YOU'LL BE TRANSPORTED BACK TO
ALL THE MOST ICONIC MOMENTS,
UNTOLD.
>> LET ME RUN THE COUNTRY AND
YOU RUN CNN AND IF YOU DID IT
WELL YOUR RATINGS --
>> BEFORE IF YOU WANTED THIS
MUCH TRUMP, YOU'D HAVE TO WATCH
THE NEWS 24/7 AND IGNORE YOUR
FAMILY COMPLETELY.
>> DON'T I KNOW IT, KAT.
MY SON STILL WON'T TALK TO ME
BUT NOW I CAN GET THE GREATEST
TRUMP MOMENTS ALL IN ONE PLACE,
WHENEVER I WANT I CAN SEE
CLASSICS LIKE GET HIM OUT OF
HERE.
>> GET HIM OUT OF HERE, PLEASE,
GET HIM OUT, OUT.
OUT, GO HOME TO MOMMY.
>> HOW WAS YOUR NAP, KAT?
>> GREAT, TOM.
EVERY CLIP TELLS A GREAT STORY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHO COULD FORGET BING, BING,
BONG, BING, BING.
>> BING, BING, BONG, BONG, YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT IS?
>> YOU WON'T FIND THIS
COLLECTION ON CNN?
>> YOU'RE TELLING ME, DO YOU
REMEMBER WHERE'S NICK?
>> NICK, STAND UP.
[APPLAUSE]
>> COME HERE.
>> GET UP HERE, NICK.
>> ORDER TRUMP HITS TODAY, CALL
ANY TIME WITHIN THE NEXT 4 YEARS
AND YOU'LL LIMITED EDITION LOCK
OF THE PRESIDENT'S HAIR, NO
ADDITIONAL CHARGE.
TRUMP HITS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST, HAS
MORE GUTS THAN BELLY CONTEST,
TECHNICIAN STAFF SERGEANT JOYE
JOE.
HIS COMEDY SPECIAL I'VE GOT THE
HOUSE NOW STREAMING EVERYWHERE,
JIM FLORENTINE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> HER GLASSES ARE THICK BUT
PART OF HER STICK, KAT TEMPF.
>> HE'S A SHOPLIFTER HE CAN
ACTUALLY LIFT AN ENTIRE SHOP,
SIDEKICK AND HOST OF ENOUGH
SAID, TYRUS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> JOE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
CAMPAIGN KICKOFF?
>> WELL, I LOVE THE VIDEO, BY
THE WAY.
CAT JUMPING.
>> STOP, STOP.
>> HE'S COOL WITH IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M A BIT OF ONE-TRICK PONY
OVER HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> LISTEN, ARGUING WITH
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS OVER THE
DEFINITION OF TRANCATION CAMP,
IF I'VE REACHED THAT LEVEL OF MY
POLITICAL CAREER, PUT A FORK
WITH ME, I'M DONE, THAT LEVEL OF
STUPIDITY DOESN'T HAVE ANY PLACE
FOR AMERICAN POLITICS WHICH
LEADS ME TO BELIEVE THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIST.
ANYWAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SHALL I STOP THERE?
>> YEAH.
>> I'M GOING TO GET MAD.
>> WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THE WEEK
SO FAR?
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS GREAT AND
GOT CRITICISM BECAUSE HE WAS
COMPLAINING THE FIRST HOUR, HE
HAS EVERY RIGHT TO COMPLAIN.
THEY'VE BEEN ON HIM, DEMOCRATS
WON'T WORK WITH THEM, MUELLER
REPORT HANGING OVER HIS HEAD,
MEDIA AGAINST HIM, MEDIA IS LIKE
A NAGGING WIFE, THEY PICK AT
HIM.
LOOK AT THE WAY HE YAWN, CAN YOU
BELIEVE IT.
>> LIKE A MAN WHO JUST GOT
DIVORCED.
>> EXACTLY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT'S WHY MY COMEDY SPECIAL
I GOT THE HOUSE.
>> DID YOU GET THE HOUSE?
>> YEAH.
>> WAS IT A NICE HOUSE?
JUST CALL ME PETEY PRENUP.
THE GUY IS AN ANIMAL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I KIND OF WANT YOU TO GET THE
MOVIE THAT YOU SAID YOU WERE IN
WHICH YOU SAID WAS WAS TITANIC
14?
>> 17, JACK'S REVENGE.
I'VE BEEN WRITING IT, YES.
>> YOU MAKE AN EXCELLENT ELDERLY
KAT TEMPF.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT AOC AND
CONCENTRATION CAMP THING, THAT
WAS SO STUPID I WAS TRYING TO
THINK OF WHAT IT WAS LIKE SO I
WROTE A BUNCH OF ANALOGIES AND I
COULDN'T FIND WHICH ONE WAS BEST
SO I WILL SAYING ALL.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING COLD HAVING A
CANCER AND PHONE DYING IS LIKE
YOUR MOM DYING, THAT'S LIKE
SAYING THAT WEARING A TIE THAT'S
TOO TIGHT IS LIKE BEING
BEHEADED, THAT'S LIKE SAYING
THAT EATING HOT SOUP AND HAVING
IT BURN YOUR MOUTH IS LIKE BEING
BURNED ALIVE WHILE EATING HOT
SOUP.
>> INTERESTING.
>> AND THAT'S LIKE SAYING
BREAKING A FINGERNAIL IS AS BAD
AS HAVING A NAIL IN YOUR FINGER.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I DON'T KNOW -- I DIDN'T KNOW
WHICH ONE TO PICK SO THEY ALL
MADE THE AIR.
>> YES, TYRUS.
>> I THINK THAT'S ACCURATE
BECAUSE THERE WERE NO
ONE-SENTENCE TO DESCRIBE THE
MORONICNESS OF WHAT SHE SAID.
>> RIGHT.
>> SOMEBODY BREAKS INTO YOUR
HOUSE, TRIPS AND FALSE AND
BREAKS THEIR NECK AND YOU GO TO
JAIL FOR MURDER BECAUSE THAT'S
KIND OF THE SAME THING.
[APPLAUSE]
>> TRUMP HAD A BIG WEEK, KICKED
IT OFF AND WE DIDN'T SEE ANY
DEMOCRATS AGAIN, LIKE IT WAS
ONCE HE GOT ON THE NEWS, THE
ONLY THING WE HAD GOING ON WAS
THEY ARE REALLY MAD AT JOE BIDEN
FOR TELLING HOW IT IS.
>> YEAH.
>> CORY BOOKER WAS MAD AT JOE
BECAUSE JOE TOLD THE TRUTH OF
ACTUALLY HAPPENED IN HISTORIC
EVENT, NOT SOMETHING HE MADE UP
ON TWITTER.
CORY BOOKER IS FUNNY TO ME, I'M
ALL FOR CIVIL RIGHTS AND
FIGHTING FOR OUR STUFF BUT GOING
AFTER JOE BIDEN, HE LED THE
LEGISLATION, EVERYBODY KNOW THAT
LYNCH MOB IS A CRIME.
IT'S OFFICIALLY A CRIME.